do you only tend to choose projects that
you know the audience will sob
uncontrollably because that's okay you
do you do it so well no I don't however
I really have found that there
strengthen my vulnerability and I never
thought that of course growing up and I
think a lot of us aren't taught that you
know when we're vulnerable that's really
how we're showing how strong we really
are ya know we see it as a weakness and
a lot of the time absolutely and it's
sort of dictated that way yeah
unfortunately so you know I'm I'm happy
that I have stuff to pull from I'm happy
that people are being changed by it and
I'm just so grateful that I get to do
what I love to do it's oh that's pretty
amazing that you get to do something
that you love isn't that great it is
amazing um when you first heard about
this story what was your reaction cuz
for me even just watching the film I
know it's a true story I know what
happened but still so unbelievable a
hundred percent I mean when I heard
about it in the news I was like okay
there's no way there's no way even
though of course on a soul level I
believe in miracles and all of those
things I just um it's hard to wrap your
head around yeah what was it like having
the family come on set you know I was
nervous because you know it's sort of
like I know this sounds silly and maybe
not a great example but you know when
you're babysitting and the mom comes
home yeah and you're like making sure
it's good you tidy excellent yes and
they're like oh no you could I have to
go do some errands but you can still
watch them and you're like oh wait so
you're gonna be here you gonna be around
okay and it's sort of that you know I
it's not even a family member coming to
see you if this is their life so yeah I
was definitely nervous but it was so I
mean loving and supportive and magical
really yeah I was so pleased to learn
that you're the one singing the song at
the end I'm standing with you yeah I
didn't know you could sing like that oh
thank you oh it's amazing
what was that process like for you
because I was reading that that's
something you've always wanted to do
yeah music was my first is my first love
you know it's also something that you
could do alone in your bedroom you know
acting you so somebody sort of have to
watch you yeah you know it's a little
different
and I met Diane at a party and I was
like itching to say hello to her and she
was like how do you think she's like
most actors think they can sing so can
you really say she's so funny I love it
just straight yeah no she yeah no time
for anything yeah which I love and you
know just having somebody that you
listen to you all of your life you know
this legendary songwriter write a song
for you and in a movie that I'm starring
in what so I'm still it's still sort of
sinking in well I have to ask this is a
third season wrapped up yeah Toby and
Kate fans are not okay except
flash-forward scene seems like they're
not together anything that you can say
well it seems that way it seems that way
however our perception is our reality
so who knows but we will find answers
out in season four okay it's like Mandy
Moore with all that makeup you know
there's something about Mandy NIH's
dynamic that like it really pulls at my
heart like a really pulls at my heart
strings and so seeing her you know at 80
years old it's like it's even when she
was getting the process done with the
prosthetics it was like okay I gotta
walk away because it's emotional